hello freak [ __ ] of why we behave the
way we do why we have the problems that
we have
yeah and part of the issue though is if
someone controls the access to
information and they want a certain area
to be told then you know it will really
color what people see and that's what's
scary and you know we see this a lot in
YouTube now yeah where there D
monetizing anyone that they see as
right-wing and you know even censoring
and removing videos it's really scary
what it is yeah it's fascinating I mean
it's it's it's it's quite fascinating to
watch it all play out and and to have
them do it like right in front of
everybody's face nobody goes what are
you doing like you are you're changing
narratives you're altering information
and they feel like they are right right
they're doing the right thing they're
promoting diversity they're promoting
liberal values and progressive ideas and
they think they're doing the right thing
I don't necessarily think they're right
though yeah it's there's a lot of
blowback though I mean this is not free
it's not free ride for Google right now
what they've done to you I mean I'm sure
there's been I mean I'm sure they're
doubling down because they don't want to
admit they're [ __ ] up if they may
admit they're [ __ ] up everybody across
the board loses that year end bonus it
becomes a real issue right
everybody gets fired but if they you
know if you look at it long term over
the long run maybe they did they have
definitely taken a hit and if someone
forces them to sit down I would love to
sit down with the guy who said that you
promote harmful gender stereotypes and
go let's go with this thing let's go
over this thing step-by-step you tell me
what's wrong yeah and just pick them
apart that's what I've always wanted but
he'll fall apart
a hundred percent I just say a bunch of
stupid social justice warrior [ __ ]
and if you just keep them in a room for
three hours of the microphone I'm gonna
look like a [ __ ] idiot there's just
no way around it you know there's no way
around it if you're just active if
you're actually going off of what you
wrote to somehow or another look I think
it's very not
just dangerous to say it promotes
harmful gender stereotypes it's
disingenuous mm-hmm and why the reason
why it's dangerous is because I could
just read what that guy said and I would
think that you're a creep and that's
dangerous to you yeah it's it's it's
dangerous towards the the marketplace of
free ideas the marketplace of ideas it's
extremely important and I would think
that if anybody would know that it would
be the people that are involved in tech
you would think so yeah I mean they're
just so wrapped up just so wrapped up
and the progressive mindset it's weird
man yeah I mean it's so related to all
this micro aggression you know speeches
violence and you know all ideas are
harmful and and of course you know some
ideas are harmful but yeah it's only
through openly discussing them can you
actually dispel some of these things by
making them you know forbidden knowledge
that's only going to attract certain
people and you know we even see this now
worth some of the YouTube videos that
are in this purgatory type state where
you know you can't really get to them
but if you know that URL you can still
find yeah yeah lists of those and
actually viewing them yeah and oh this
is what YouTube doesn't want us to see
maybe there's some truth to it well I
don't they wanted to see it yeah if you
win a certain amount of money are you
willing to buy a gold-plated Ferrari and
drive around with a fur coat because I
think they'd be [ __ ] big-ass crazy
sunglasses oh yeah you can win I don't
really know and I mean I'm trying to I
mean what I would ideally want is
somehow changing their policies but I
don't really know how I as an individual
can you compel Google to do something
like that but I think at least some of
the stuff like the blacklisting where
they have these people that you know
compile these spreadsheets of names of
people that are conservative bright or
even libertarian and oh we're not going
to work with them we're gonna sabotage
their work and we're going to try to get
them
when they are looking for another job
we're gonna share this list so they
can't get hired from any of the other
major companies like that needs to
that's real yeah that's really you know
that that's real have you seen this list
yeah so there have been multiple people
that have admitted to having a blacklist
Wow it's so Therrien not even
conservative not even right-wing but
smaller government libertarian yeah just
because it's generally free-thinking
people yeah not telling the party line
and those people get blacklisted really
yeah there's an actual list somewhere I
think have you seen an actual list I
haven't seen an individual list I I
think there's multiple lists spread out
but people even like high up managers
have admitted to having us blacklist Wow
and you know we've brought this up to
the highest people at Google and they
just completely just missed it like
we're not gonna deal with it so do you
feel like they feel that they have some
sort of a social responsibility to push
progressive values because they're in
this massive position of influence and
they feel like that's the right way to
think so they're going to go full steam
ahead yeah and don't be evil don't be
conservative pretty much yeah mmm the
libertarian man boy so [ __ ] tough
sell to say that Gary Johnson's evil you
know I don't know but yeah it's it's
really hard to understand that mindset
yeah well I get it though because I
think it's a lot of the same things
along the same lines that you were
talking about when you were saying that
you didn't you know like maybe you would
have waited till you got your year-end
bonus and you're a guy who is also
frugal you've saved your money and you
don't have a family to support and
you're okay you know you got fired and
you're still okay you know whereas some
people would be [ __ ] right now maybe
they didn't overextended maybe they have
that gold Ferrari in the fur coat and
like [ __ ] yeah I mean if I had a
mortgage or something
it's scary that's where it gets scary
that's a lot of people's decision-making
I mean that's that goes back to you know
engineering civilization and the early
days of Rome I think there was writings
about that about getting people to
commit to families and it's easier to
control them when they help other ones
and and you know and things that they
enjoy and positions of power and status
that it's easier to get those people to
give in to your needs and desires yeah I
mean it makes sense right I mean it's
just engineering a civilization it's one
of the like getting people to perform
and behave the way that you would like
them to is a critical component of
engineering any sort of a civilization
and Google is essentially a civilization
if you look at it that way
I mean internally there's a is a
community it's a structure and they're
engineering that structure to be very
much a like-minded ideological echo
chamber
[Applause]
[Music]